[Música]
al futuro
tenemos futuro queremos futuro
parece una pregunta obvia es un
determinante biológico y sin embargo por
cómo reaccionamos por cómo hacemos cosas
no estoy tan seguro que esto sea así
si le preguntan a los ambientalistas
apocalípticos el futuro es bastante
oscuro
el cambio climático la invasión de
especies exóticas la contaminación el
sobreuso
diríamos que desde esa perspectiva el
futuro al menos es no es muy extenso
si le preguntan a los desarrollistas a
ultranza el futuro no solamente es
maravilloso si no es muy halagüeño
desde esta perspectiva la tecnología el
crecimiento económico permanente la
equidad
va a generar una sociedad de bienestar
y ninguno de los dos está mintiendo cada
uno de ellos tienen sus elementos para
suponer que es posible
para la ciencia ni el optimismo ni el
pesimismo son opciones la ciencia tiene
que partir de la generación de datos
hacia la información hacia el
conocimiento y más recientemente hacia
la interfaz política hacia mostrar todo
ese conocimiento para la toma de
decisiones
también depende de a quien se le haga la
pregunta
si es al planeta y permanentemente lo
discutimos en nuestras conversaciones el
planeta tiene al menos el doble de
tiempo que ha estado
dándole vueltas al sol el planeta
requiere la energía solar y la ha tenido
permanente durante los últimos cuatro
mil quinientos o cinco mil millones de
años y el sol tiene la reserva de fisión
nuclear de hidrógeno y de ellos
suficiente para otros cinco mil millones
de años más
el planeta parece no tener mayores
inconvenientes no es una pregunta que
lee
importe y adicionalmente
hacia 1970 en esa década james lovelock
un autor norteamericano planteó la
teoría gaia
en la teoría gaia el planteamiento es
que el planeta es una especie de ser
consciente que logra regular sus ciclos
su ciclo de carbono su ciclo de agua su
ciclo de nitrógeno su ciclo de fosfato
de manera que no tiene mayores
inconvenientes y de hecho nosotros somos
un mal menor como una especie de fiebre
que ni siquiera genera mayor
preocupación
ahora si la pregunta está vinculada a la
especie que tanto futuro tiene la
especie la preocupación tampoco es mayor
este es una especie relativamente nueva
los mamíferos tienen en promedio entre 1
y 2 millones de años de duración antes
de convertirse en otra especie
y nosotros apenas tenemos entre 750.000
y 400.000 años o sea que en el peor de
los casos la especie podría tener
incluso el doble de tiempo del que ha
estado en el planeta
sin embargo cuando lo que nos
preguntamos es si la civilización si la
humanidad si como nos reconocemos como
sociedad tienen futuro
hay unos umbrales de incertidumbre
realmente grandes
ahí es donde conviene poner
el dedo sobre la llaga estamos agotando
los recursos del planeta de wwf viene
planteando por ejemplo que el 89 por
ciento de las poblaciones silvestres de
fauna y flora de centro y suramérica han
desaparecido
y los dos grados de cambio climático que
solicito él
el panel de cambio climático en parís
hace unos años son tímidamente
respondidas por los gobiernos bajo esas
perspectivas realmente tenemos
dificultades para suponer esa
resiliencia
sin embargo la situación de colombia no
es la peor colombia a diferencia de lo
anteriormente mencionado es un país que
tiene la proporción de áreas
de áreas naturales y de áreas
transformadas contraria al resto del
planeta si el planeta tiene una tercera
parte natural y dos terceras partes
transformadas sucede lo contrario en
colombia tenemos dos terceras partes
naturales y una tercera parte
transformada
en apenas el 1% de la tierra que hay en
el planeta del territorio continental
del planeta
se alberga el 10 por ciento de las
poblaciones del planeta eso en otras
palabras quiere decir que tenemos 10
veces más que el promedio que puede
querer decir incluso 100 veces más que
el que menos tiene
11 países tienen el 70 por ciento del
agua dulce del planeta colombia es uno
de ellos colombia es el primer
territorio donde hay más aves y donde
hay más orquídeas es el segundo en
anfibios mariposas y peces de agua dulce
es el tercero en plantas y reptiles es
el cuarto de mamíferos
y no es el país más grande es un país de
apenas un millón de kilómetros cuadrados
de tamaño intermedio y buena parte de
los otros países que digamos tienen un
ranking mejor son países
considerablemente más grandes
sin embargo no todo es tranquilidad
nuestro país tiene inmensos problemas
alrededor de la sostenibilidad la
resiliencia parece ser un soporte grande
para la sociedad y sin embargo hay
muchas cosas por hacer por mencionar
algunas
el convenio de diversidad biológica que
es el organismo rector de los países
para temas de conservación del medio
ambiente propuso una meta en hace unos
45 años de que debíamos tener el 17 por
ciento del territorio terrestre
conservado en área terrestre y el 10 por
ciento el marino el país cumplió lo
marino con excelencia el que el país
está cumpliendo los terrestres muy
próximamente y los países de la región
han logrado también tener unas metas de
conservación por encima de las que
planteó el convenio diversidad biológica
y sin embargo seguimos perdiendo
biodiversidad en ese contexto que
estamos haciendo mal es el mecanismo por
medio del cual estamos haciendo
conservación de biodiversidad o de
pronto de lo que estamos hablando es del
paradigma con el cual estamos haciendo
gestión de biodiversidad en los 70
cuando estaba trabajando yo con áreas
protegidas en el inderena el contexto
era la tragedia de los comunes que
propuso un biólogo jardín en 1976
en 2008 elinor ostrom gana el premio
nobel de economía hablando del medio
ambiente y proponiendo un paradigma
diferente que es la gobernanza de
recursos la gobernanza comunitaria de
recursos naturales ese tránsito
paradigmático lo tenemos no lo tenemos
que creer tenemos que convertirlo en
elementos de gestión de hecho habría que
plantear que el mismo concepto de la
preservación puede ser incluso
antinatural la preservación supone dejar
algo estático y lo único estático en la
biodiversidad es la dinámica de manera
que la preservación dejaría muchas dudas
alrededor de que sea un buen referente
para la conservación de la biodiversidad
al menos hay que suponer que no podemos
seguir haciendo más de lo mismo que
tenemos que innovar que tenemos que ser
consecuentes con estos tránsitos de
paradigma y convertir cada vez en
mejores herramientas para la gestión de
la biodiversidad
la balanza económica del país se basa en
elementos de extracción recursos que se
extraen del territorio el carbón el
petróleo el oro y colombia- en ningún
caso es ninguno de los primeros 10 en
petróleo somos el 21 en carbón somos el
11 en oro ni siquiera alcanzamos a estar
dentro de los primeros 20 mientras que
la inversión en temas de biotecnología
biomímesis elementos bio está bastante
limitada de manera que tendríamos que
hacer una enorme gestión alrededor de
investigación ciencia conocimiento hacia
patentes y hacia la posibilidad de que
haya elementos de la economía a partir
de lo que hacia donde planeta se está
moviendo nada diferente que es una de
las aproximaciones que para que mejor se
están desarrollando actualmente de la de
las transiciones socio ecológicas hacia
la sostenibilidad
este concepto pretende entrar en la
gestión ambiental
del antropoceno no seguir pensando en
gestión ambiental del pleistoceno de
hace mucho tiempo de volver a recuperar
los territorios naturales todo cambia
pero cambia o posibilidades de que siga
siendo funcional
estocolmo en 1972 la primera cumbre de
la tierra planteó el desarrollo
sostenible como el gran eslogan
la cumbre de río de janeiro en 1992
planteo actuar local y pensar global
siguen siendo válidas tenemos que seguir
pensando en esa localidad en actuar y
buena parte de ustedes y el
ambientalismo es muy fuerte en colombia
alrededor de ese actuar local sin
embargo pensar global es necesario pero
incluso al margen de lo que esperemos de
los gobiernos o de lo que hagamos como
estado la responsabilidad de la
conservación de la biodiversidad y de la
gestión ambiental es de todos y de cada
uno de ustedes cualquiera de las
decisiones diarias que toman alrededor
de el plástico el mercado con bolsa
y la movilidad sostenible depende
exclusivamente de usted no podemos
seguirles exigiendo a los gobiernos que
hagan lo que nosotros tenemos que
empezar a hacer y luego claro presionar
a los gobiernos para que se cumplan
estos elementos
pongo un tema corto rápido
me movilizó en bicicleta al menos
durante este siglo eso es lo que hago
pero ya ni siquiera por conciencia
ambiental ni por compromiso social es
que la generación de endorfinas que
produce la movilidad
en bicicleta en bogotá generan los
niveles de adicción a los que ya estoy
sometido
les invito a reflexionar ya tomar
decisiones conscientes gracias
[Aplausos]